les partisans des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle commence à s'impatienter
depuis plusieurs jours des centaines
d'indigènes équatorien manifestent dans
les rues de la capitale quito pour
soutenir leurs favoris à la présidence
de l'équateur et à coup perez selon les
résultats encore provisoires du premier
tour publiés ce jeudi cet avocat
écologistes arrive troisième du scrutin
avec 19,42 % des voix il est devancé de
peu par le conservateur guillermo olaso
crédité de 19,72 % des suffrages et donc
pour l'instant qualifié pour le second
tour mais devant ses fidèles
yakou perez dénonce une manipulation ils
commettent une fraude flagrante
est ce qu'ils font c'est laisser
endommager gravement la démocratie la
démocratie actuelle est une caricature
un théâtre de mauvais goût cela
m'attriste terriblement ils ne veulent
pas les votes pour rien coup perez ils
veulent tout un projet tout un rêve tout
un espoir que les équatoriens avait le
candidat indigènes réclamant recomptage
des voix dans plusieurs provinces dont
les quatre qui ont le plus grand nombre
d'électeurs au premier tour une demande
soutenue par son adversaire guillermo
olaso de son côté andrey saros large
vainqueur du premier tour avec plus de
32 % des voix exprimées demande à ses
rivaux de garder leur calme
tous les acteurs politiques impliqués
dans ce processus électoral à être
patient à agir avec prudence et nous
appelons à la non-violence à maintenir
une situation pacifique
tous les autres points à résoudre dans
le cadre du processus électoral devrait
être réglée dans le respect des
principes démocratiques et des
mécanismes institutionnels approprié
alors que le conseil national électoral
n'a pas encore publié des résultats d
ni tiff la mission d'observation envoyée
par l'organisation des états américains
recommandent elle aussi aux candidats de
faire preuve de responsabilité et à la
population d'attendre les résultats dans
le calme
en attendant le conseil national
électoral est protégé par l'armée
envoyées en renfort